i don't wanna work
i just wanna bang on this muggle did you
ask me here for any specific reason uh
yes i did
a touch of scranton business park there
will be complimentary pretzels available
in the lobby from now until four
once a year they bring in a little cart
and they give away free pretzels it's
really not a big deal
to some people it is
productivity is important but how can i
be productive if i have this one little
thing in my brain that i cannot get out
and that one little thing is a soft
pretzel
so i'm just gonna have my soft pretzel
i'll get to work and i'm gonna be super
productive look out for me
oh shh
come on
hi please tell me you have a sweet
pretzel left we do
thank and we have 18 different toppings
we have sweet glaze cinnamon sugar
chocolate white chocolate fudge m ms
caramel dip mint chip chocolate chip
marshmallows nuts toffee nuts coconut
peanut butter drizzle oreo sprinkles
cotton candy bits and powdered sugar
is there any way that you could do all
all of them the works you got it all
right
thank you
thunder mifflin this is pam
oh hi jan
he's uh on a sales call no message
bye jan
commission comes out too
zero
okay well it can't be zero kev i entered
the sale and
i hit enter and i said
i'm pretty sure i timesed it right you
met your commission cap last week so
from here until the end of the fiscal
year your commission will be zero what
are you talking about we we have a
commission cap it's a new corporate
policy
is this job really about the money for
you jim i mean isn't this where you fell
in love a commission cap takes away my
incentive to sell so you realize i now
have no reason to work right
well since i have no incentive to sell
i've cleaned my car organized my desk
and taken a multivitamin so
what now
pam
okay now i've tried everything did you
prank dwight no well you like that yeah
it's not as fun if i'm not blowing off
work i love you but i'm kind of busy so
i need you to figure this one out on
your own
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh nice wasting time here we go hey back
off it's solitaire
hey kid
here you're looking for work talk to me
how far can you reach those lovely long
arms here's
yeah but now
how long can you hold that pretty little
breath of yours
good
hey jim
are you distracting these people
we're working
you at least try to look busy
toby doesn't h.r have some rules against
talking about this kind of stuff
hearing aids are it's a joke i can't do
anything about anything
hey ryan could you start consolidating
all our rolodex information into outlook
uh it doesn't seem like there's much of
a point if the company's going under but
if the company doesn't go under then
we'll finally have all our contacts in
one program company's probably going
under to go either way seems like it's
leaning one way maybe we should just
wait and find out definitely okay so
should we wait to find out before we
start doing all this stuff nah
might as well do it now
hey ryan how's it going
here's the thing um
i've tried it like five different ways
in my head
and oh got one um
i'm such a perfectionist
that i'd kind of rather not do it at all
than do a crappy version simple data
entry though so there's really only one
way to do it sounds like you have a
really specific vision for it do you
want to maybe just take a while at it
you know what what i think i know the
problem great i think you seem
distracted yep that is the problem
you playing that game again second life
is not a game
it is a multi-user virtual environment
it doesn't have points or scores it
doesn't have winners or losers oh it has
losers
i signed up for second life about a year
ago
back then my life was so great that i
literally wanted a second one in my
second life i was also a paper salesman
and i was also named white
absolutely everything was the same
except i could fly
you've got no taste family hudson oh i
do what are you guys talking about some
actress whether she's hot
who's the gal in question hillary swank
no
hillary swank
not at
have you seen her with her all
she looks like a monster guys she is a
beautiful movie star so maybe we should
just go to work she is an amazing
actress that's not the question she's
not hot yeah thank you okay okay okay
why don't we just put this to a vote and
then we'll be done with it i'm not
voting no one cares who thinks that
hillary swank is hot raise your hand
okay and who thinks that hillary swank
is not hot
five five to five thank you accounting
department
so what do we do now each side will have
three minutes to prepare opening
arguments topic
hillary swank is attractive
the debate is whether she's hot what
difference does it make attractive hot
beautiful we're talking about the same
thing here huge difference
a painting can be beautiful but i don't
want to bang a painting okay
tmi see that
the obvious symmetry of the face
this is a natural appeal of the
scientific standard of
coinophilia
features that are composite average of
many features yes she's attractive but
she's not hot
kevin
would you like to do the change from
last week yes why him don't whine
get the windows
previously on varsity blues
okay billy bob got a head injury but
coach made him play so then lance he
gets sacked and he's out for the year
hello not everyone approves of movie
monday
i won't say who
i don't approve
i don't
hello
let's go after that time now
let's go let's go
let's go
hi dan hope you got the milk duds
how would a movie increase productivity
michael how on earth would it do that
people work faster after
magically
no
they have to to make up for the time
they lost
watching the movie
when i discovered youtube i didn't work
for five days i did
nothing i viewed cookie monster sings
chocolate rain about a thousand times
when i discovered youtube i didn't work
for five days i did nothing i viewed
cookie monster sings chocolate rain
about a thousand times
you